bring it on Hello everyone and welcome
back to binge battle here at Rotten
Tomatoes I am your host Mark Ellis and
in the world of Game of Thrones War I am
what you would say not a newbie I'm
definitely not an experienced veteran
like our two panelists today but I am a
fan of this stuff including the new show
House of the Dragon which just concluded
it's season one run and the ratings were
pretty good people really like anything
in the world of Game of Thrones if
you're in Westeros if your last name
happens to be a Lannister or a Targaryen
or some of the newer names a Hightower
that we're learning for the first time
this is a show that takes place before
all of the fun events that we saw in
Game of Thrones way before as a matter
of fact there's some time jumping it's a
whole lot of fun seems like a lot of
folks enjoyed it but that's why we're
here to talk about today because it's
binge battle and how do we celebrate art
here we make it a wee bit competitive we
have two experts that are going to be
debating some of the Hot Topics who do
you like who didn't you like what do you
feel about the season overall what are
you anticipating in season two all that
and more and I'm being told in my ear I
actually think at least one of them
might have read some of the source
material that is a gold star in my book
because I didn't do that what I will do
right now is Usher a spoiler warning as
we do here on bench battle we're going
to get deep into this stuff so if you've
not yet seen House of the Dragon if
you're one of those folks that did watch
House of the Dragon but not Game of
Thrones yet you might have some stuff
revealed in there as well so if you
please maybe go check out House of the
Dragon get steeped in Game of Thrones
lore and then come on back here and
enjoy the show afterwards or just watch
and get spoiled and learn how to hang
out of your office water cooler tomorrow
it's gonna be a fun one kids and we have
two great panelists here on the show
that probably have been to
rottentomatoes.com once or twice in
their life that is going to be your hub
for all things streaming TV movies
everywhere in between House of the
Dragon updates just head over to
rottentomatoes.com and with that
time to introduce our first guest today
making their debut on binge battle but
if you're a fan of Star Wars you
probably listen to his podcast octo
radio or you may have checked out
casterly talk which yes as the name
implies does cover House of the dragon
all them Diaz is here Alden it is a
pleasure to finally after long waiting
for all of our fans welcome you to binge
battle oh thank you so much Mark for the
warm welcome I feel like you raised my
banners and flags you had trumpets and
everything it this is a nice Castle
you've got here I'm just sorry that
there's going to be Bloodshed it's just
a it's a humble manner that I have here
at Ellis House West I will ask you Alden
when House of the Dragon was announced
that we're getting this show the last
season of Game of Thrones I think it's
fair to say mixed reaction from the
viewers from critics from the fans so
House of the Dragon Gets announced are
you over the moon about this are you
hesitant that we're getting back into
this world so quickly oh I was
absolutely over the moon because season
eight controversial as it may be left me
feeling like post breakup and I was like
I want more I don't care if we had a
poisonous time uh I definitely wanted to
immediately see the world again and
through a new angle they immediately say
hey we're going back and if you watch
Game of Thrones you knew back then a lot
of crazy stuff happened it's what I
believe in the future of humanity
because these kids they're ready to get
right back up on the horse now you're a
few months younger than your competitor
but you could sort of look at y'all's
relationship as maybe you're the Protege
to his mentors that fair to say
uh I think it is fair to say and you
know I don't want to reference another
fantasy but you ever hear the tragedy of
Darth Kenneth the wise and what happened
to him uh somebody got slained by their
own apprentice and there's a lot of
apprentice and master fighting in Game
of Thrones as well yeah it tends to
happen whether your swords are Valyrian
steel or they're from a kyber crystal
let's meet your opponent now he is a
returning favorite here a former
champion on binge battle he is also a
host of casterly talk and he also does
this Star Wars podcast for Center to
worldwide Acclaim he wrote the book on
Star Wars why we love Star Wars and he's
a fantastic stand-up comic if you can
catch him performing in your town Ken
knapsock can the student is now meeting
the master you you know Alden you guys
worked together on casterly talk but now
it's time to really get your ideas in a
competitive format look this this is
great Mark I love this opportunity I
will point out that Darth Plagueis the
Wise in Legends was killed by his
Apprentice Palpatine because Plagueis
just wanted to sleep and didn't care
what happened and that's truly what
happens the older you get they'll happy
to be here Alton is a great broadcaster
insightful commentator uh and this is
going to be a lot of fun I don't have to
talk about lightsabers this time just
swords you just get to talk about the
metal when you first heard House of the
Dragon was announced any apprehension in
the knapsack household about how soon
it's coming on the heels of Game of
Thrones did you want more time to be
passed or were you just ready to jump
right back in I absolutely uh was in
love with the idea loving the idea of it
expanding just in terms of story
expanding in terms of an IP from a
business point of view just makes a lot
of sense this world is big and large
yeah it gave it Game of Thrones season
eight and season seven and six there's a
lot of controversies I get it I'm a big
fan of season eight because uh when you
follow the themes and trace it back to
the start of that show I think they
really uh hit the mark and I was excited
to learn more and plus different
creators different voices involved so it
was going to have a different feel
regardless all right so I'm being told
in my ear I believe it's somewhere
around 170 years before Daenerys
Targaryen was born we've heard of that
one haven't we kiddos and so that's when
this show takes place but there is some
jumping around here as we tend to do in
binge battle we round hop and this is
how the show is going to work each one
of those rounds four total at least
we're prepared for a fifth tiebreaker
round should it come down to that you're
gonna have three different segments you
have your opening argument that can go
up to a minute then you have a rebuttal
after hearing what your opponent feels
that could be up to 30 seconds then you
each have one final statement mic drop
moment try to keep that one pretty tidy
around 10 to 15 seconds the spoiler
alert is in effect and with that we are
off and running here on binge battle
with our topic number one in round one
and it goes to Ken knapsock first can
the question is simply your overall
thoughts on the season finale of the
great season that was season one of
House of the Dragon the overall thoughts
on season one and specifically finale
was that this was great it did what it
wanted to do it had a big important
powerful message it also knew it had to
have a little bit more finer point in
what it was talking about in terms of
social issues how it handled the tough
conversations but it still stuck to the
brand which is in your face sometimes
putting things out there that are yeah a
little over top a little violent a
little ancestrual and uh that is all to
a big thematic point and I thought it
all came together in a great finale that
really set us up for the next season but
uh did not stray far from the themes of
the show and the characters and the
lessons and the choices and it ends with
one of my favorite shots pissed off
renera saying all right War they want
war it shall be the dragons are about to
dance loved it yeah it was pretty
exciting way to leave us all salivating
for more there so we have a very
positive response from Ken knapsock
Alden Diaz now the round goes to you
well you won't find me disagreeing that
this was a great season but I would also
like to point out not only is this a
great season it's a great thing for nerd
culture it's a great thing for all of us
that love these worlds because this I
will say it now is the new standard for
prequel storytelling I think the word
prequel scares a lot of people but I
think that this is the gold standard
this is the thing that can expand upon
those ideas and tell you why sometimes
you need to go back I think they're in
the Multiverse out there there's a
lesser version of this show that maybe
it starts with oh here's this King and
he's dead and here's where the dance
pops off but not this show this show
said no you need Phantom Menace you need
Better Call Saul this show stuck up for
every prequel that's ever existed in its
greatness and said this is why we need
to expand on The Souls of the characters
and the themes the blood the gore even
the incest but the dragons the dragons
cover up for the incest that's that's
the soul of it is telling you why we got
here I I like that equation dragons
bouncing out incest that seems fair to
me anyway
um Ken let's go back to you and for both
these rebuttals I'm curious to have your
answers more geared let's just talk
about that finale a little bit and where
it left you did you feel as strongly
about the finale as you did the overall
season
uh in some ways the finale was my
favorite episode that does not
necessarily mean it was the best episode
it was my favorite one because it like I
said it built on what uh came before but
we knew a war was gonna happen much like
the chihuahuas you might be hearing in
the background here at my home studio I
can't get rid of them uh yeah so no uh
this all leads to what we needed to to
get which is this idea of War uh from
Monera but the the honest choice to get
there the lessons learned from viserys
all right so Alden let's go over to you
for your rebuttal again let's stick to
that finale and just how it left you
sort of waiting for the next season I
think a lot of the power of the finales
and the small details and the things you
don't see yes I agree it gave us all
these things about Rainier it gave us
all these lessons being crystallized but
if you're creating the Game of Thrones
prequel for the world and you've got to
solidify this and send us into what
looks like a long off season you throw
in names like Baratheon you throw in
names like Aaron and you throw in names
like Stark Craig and Stark is coming
someone's going north and I think that
was the perfect note to send everybody
off into this weight thinking about
knowing that oh yeah the Game of Thrones
are back on yeah it's it's not a
rebuilding off season it's just a season
filled with new prospects we're hoping
to pick up in the draft in sports terms
Ken your Dolphins seem to be playing
okay but are they playing as well as
this first season gave you
uh yeah absolutely that also includes
some losses this this uh this season did
bring up some things that uh some time
jumps everything that might have been
hard uh but I I really do think it laid
the structure the foundation for what's
going to come in this dance of the
Dragons All right a good last statement
from Ken the final statement now and the
last word in the round goes to Alden I
think that the greatest compliment that
we can give this show is that it managed
to be two seasons in one young Allison
young renera we fell in love with them
in five episodes and then boom they're
gone and we're in this other place and
it made you fall in love again they
managed to double cast this thing until
a multi-faceted story that left us all
mouths again
all right so I mean two great arguments
is not necessarily going against each
other as you both are celebrating this
show and so if I'm looking at how to
score this round you don't want to kick
off a show with a tie I believe the
saying is aged before Beauty but the
fact that the beauty could hold its own
with the age and Alden being so much
younger than Ken I buy a couple weeks
here Ken is what I'm saying Alden is
gonna get the point here in round number
one and so Alden goes up on the master
to the Padawan one to nothing but
it's just the beginning and now we head
to round number two where we are going
to get specifically into the episodes
themselves and which one was your
favorite probably loved them all you got
to pick one and this time we're starting
with Alden who's got a one point lead
what was your favorite episode of season
one
for season one I have to go with episode
eight the lord of the tides this will go
down as the viserys death episode it all
built to this we saw him in the pilot
with just a little back sore just a
little [ __ ] little sore on his back we
didn't know what was going on and now
here he is rotting decomposing he's
missing an eye he needs a mask to even
just keep his face together it's not
just burns there's no face and what does
he do the most triumphant forward
movement since Rocky ran up those steps
except it was an old man just saying hey
daughter I didn't forget about you I
meant what I said I love you and then on
top of that the most roguish sometimes
disgusting and dastardly Brothers saying
Hey brother and I love you it was this
is for the lovers this episode was for
the families hey kid's good he even
referenced Rocky which is the franchise
that I stole that age before a beauty
line from at the end of Rocky 3 and
referenced in Rocky IV so Ken it's an
uphill climb for you now railing one to
nothing your favorite episode I know you
all both like the finale but you have an
episode that you like more than episode
eight yeah and I tell you what I feel
like a veteran that's lost his fastball
today and the pitches aren't hitting but
here's the thing
um uh yeah favorite episode I don't know
it might be the finale but I just didn't
seem to be fair to me I think the best
episode and also therefore the one I
really gravitate the most to is episode
five we light the way directed by Claire
uh Kilner Charmaine de grate is the
writer of that one and uh this episode
is truly a midpoint this is the last
episode with the younger cast so to
speak there's some different ages up
that course happened after this but it
is Young Allison it is Young Ranier and
if you go to this episode this is where
everyone has a choice you could have
titled this episode the choices and
every character has a choice to make and
they could pull back from uh the war
that might come decades later uh they
could pull back from the uh the Intrigue
the politics the politicking uh the
Machiavellian kind of stuff that we come
to know and love in this land but for
various reasons or other uh they all
move forward and this is the last
episode which I felt that Sarah's had
any sense of control and he's left there
just hammering a lobster just trying to
cut it because he's lost control as the
older generation watches the new
generation carry the hate forward they
don't solve the problems they choose to
move forward with the ill will and their
heart it's a key episode it ends
controversially hey what episode of Game
of Thrones and House of dragon doesn't
have that but it's a powerful episode
and I think when you look at the long
run this will be one of the key ones it
was it that handling of the lobster
reminded me and probably no one else of
the beginning of naked gun two and a
half with Frank drebin at the White
House dinner go back and watch it it's
the best of that series kids let's go
back to Alden now for his rebuttal lord
of the tides I think in terms we're
talking about this greater tapestry Game
of Thrones we love to look back at Game
of Thrones season one especially with
someone like Ned Stark played by the
incredible Sean Bean and say that's
where it all went wrong right there
that's where you goofed and you just You
could argue that lord of the tides is
the Tipping Point it ends with the death
of viserys and we get to see sort of how
these characters maybe could have chosen
a better path that dinner has wholesome
moments the villain of the show clapping
and smiling and saying good job to the
Next Generation but people choose their
worst instincts I think this is the
episode that says hey don't forget what
Universe you're in both of these
episodes very interesting you all picked
five and eight because you are seeing
characters forced to make choices for
really the first time in the series that
you're going to have better consequences
that we'll probably see throughout
season two and Beyond Ken knapsock back
to you for your rebuttal I love episode
eight and I I was touched by the death
of viserys Targaryen but here's the
thing he was already dead man he had
died long before that it was up to the
next people around him the next
Generation decide what to do with it in
this episode we light the way is the one
in which Otto tells Allison do you want
to hang and hope for Mercy from a narrow
do you want to take the throne do you
want to put your son on that throne and
then he had raniera had the opportunity
to run away with sirenso which was the
name Alden gave Fabian Frankel's
character Kristen Cole uh she doesn't do
that and also it ends with the
controversy but also ends with Kristen
Cole go in a certain direction that's
always going to be a part of Allison's
uh future going forward uh the house of
self-righteousness the high towers and
she shoves up with the green dress what
a moment war was declared there it's
always dangerous having a big fancy
function in this universe because
someone's going to show up late and it's
probably not going to end well Alden
back to you for your final statement
here in round number two in support of
episode 8. well you know dinners
weddings they're all great but in
Westeros there are sometimes business
events like a meeting to decide a line
of succession and I don't think there
has ever been one that ended in as
cataclysmic and shocking away as vaman
valarian losing part of his head keeping
his tongue though as Damon is a man of
his word he loves the theatrics I think
that moment will stick out and when you
combine that with the last show of
strength of viserys I don't think he was
already dead in this episode I do think
he had one more thing in him and I think
he proved in the end great king perhaps
not great father great brother
absolutely
good family man if nothing else can
napstock You're A solid family fella as
well you have the final statement here
in round two if family is the staff at
my local Del Taco yes that is me Here's
the final statement on it this is the
story of the greens and the blacks at
episode five we light the way is about
the green sand we are stepping up we are
making choices Lara strong giving
Allison that speech you are a flower
that's not supposed to survive here you
have to make that choice it was big
episode for that and for the conflict
that is coming out and coming our way
he's not just a walking modern zag it's
got a fast food establishments he is a
fan of House of the dragon and it's a
tough call here because one of the tides
was one of those Mark episodes that you
watch and you say okay I need to go back
and study this after the new season
comes out to see what tea leaves they're
dropping here I found a lord of the
tides fan of the Barbra Streisand Nick
Nolte film The Prince of Tides but
episode 5 for me sort of was the one
that shifted into high gear in the same
way that you could say maybe episode
five or six of rings of power really got
us fully ingratiated in that world after
setting it up and one of the keys for me
was just having the betrothal with the
madness that ensues including some
character named Joffrey meeting their
end if your name is Joffrey in this
franchise you're not getting out alive
you're not going to be around for long
enjoy the time you have it's a close
call here but Ken knapsock does get the
point here in round at number two two
great competitors great arguments so for
and now we come to the round that I
might have been most looking forward to
this round just because there's so many
characters and a lot of us are still
figuring out wait that's the person and
whose name is that it really is homework
that you got to do watching this show
but it's rewarding because we get to be
enriched by all these new fellas and
folks and ladies and everyone in between
that we're meeting for the very first
time let's go to Ken apsock first
kicking us off here in round three who
is the best character in House of the
Dragon best character of house the
Dragon season one I'll add that comma
and I will say this I'll start with an
apology for rhaenyra Targaryen and
Allison Hightower this is a season
that's about them and their relationship
to this world and relationship to each
other but I I will use the rest of my
time to say it's viserys Targaryen the
first Patty Constantine lead singer of
riding the Low by the way who uh just
gave this heartfelt performance that was
the core of this season but also I think
we'll find as The Show Goes On It will
be something a lot of characters will
look back and the story will reflect on
good man bad King and this is a show and
a world that's often about who's on the
throne and how do you get there and what
do you do with it and this was a
heartbreaking example of someone who
avoids conflict who tries to make
everyone happy tries to do it for the
realm keeps peace but really does he and
it costs him in the end and he slowly
slowly dies even Patty's saying that
about the character he died in episode
one it just slowly slowly happened over
eight episodes it ends beautifully in
alden's episode that he looked talked
about their lord of the tides it's
painful and uh like Ned Stark's death
that was big and dramatic but Ned
Stark's influence has felt even Eight
Episodes eight seasons later I think
viserys will be felt as this show and
Story Goes On yeah I mean you even you
you feel the Ned start touch right
through the end of game of thrones's run
could the same be said for this
Targaryen uh let's go to Alden are you
taking a different house or are you
staying in this family
oh we're staying in the family and I
can't think of anyone more appropriate
to put up against Ken's viserys than my
younger roguish brother Damon Targaryen
Damon Targaryen the Rogue Prince the
writer of the blood worm caraxis is the
apotheosis of why we love this world
this guy is everything he is sensitive
sad younger brother he is trying to
express his love but he is also a sadist
he is also the baddest warrior in the
land he is also maybe a little too
interested in his niece but hey we loved
Jamie and Cersei we've excused worse uh
relatively speaking and this entire
Dynamic that he has with viserys with
bernera with all these people shows a
character who ultimately is the perfect
Rogue character for today for 2022 and
Beyond this is the young guy online
who's like I don't want to be perceived
I just wanted to find my own story this
is the most relatable and sometimes in
scary ways character that I've ever
experienced in this world and also Matt
Smith from Doctor Who to Westeros
absolutely crushing it even that detour
in the British history on the crowd yeah
I mean you all to pick two fantastic
actors portraying these characters Patty
consonant and then everyone was excited
when uh Doctor Who Um gets announced in
anything really I mean whether it's it's
Star Wars or it's this world with House
of the Dragon back to Ken knapsock
stumping for an older Targaryen
yeah this is the dividing lines between
us the old and the young here there's so
many oh yeah I love Damon Targaryen I
really do he's a wonderful character and
I became more of a Matt Smith fan
because of this but he's a bad guy boo
hits this man all his heart all his uh
nice Sweet Moments he killed his first
wife bludgeoned her with a rock after
she fell off her horse and her horse
crushed her he's a bad man and there's
lessons to learn from him which is why I
do love the character the saris is the
heart and soul and there's lessons to
learn from him that I think have more
more far-reaching uh effects for society
including uh you know dealing with the
toxic males like Damon in our world and
our lives viserys failed to do that in
some of the biggest lessons in Game of
Thrones and House of dragon are from the
failures of characters like him all
right the Sarah is coming into the real
world and teaching us something about
ourselves back to Alden for his rebuttal
your honor I would like to move to
dismiss the uh spousal murder uh that
was brought up by one Kenneth no I mean
it's a valid point but think about the
characters that Define this world
someone like Jaime Lannister who I've
mentioned who was a character that took
us on a journey we never expected in
Game of Thrones unless you read the
books of course this guy Begins the show
with an attempted child murder that
almost succeeded ruined this kid's life
in a lot of ways and changed it forever
Damon is that type of character who is
capable of all things you cannot look
away you are constantly compelled and he
makes you question yourself as a piece
of writing as a performance this
character is everything he might not be
teaching you the best lessons but he is
showing you exactly what this show is at
all times you are gonna have to forgive
some murders if if you want to root for
any character really in Game of Thrones
or House of the Dragon you got to be
willing to move on and have a short
memory Ken knapslock back to you for
your final statement here in round three
House of the Dragon season one was a
wonderful sprawling epic but it was also
very somber Game of Thrones succeeds
with humor and heart as well and viserys
provided that time and time again some
of the funny moments the lobster him
going yes my kids are my grandchildren
are fighting isn't this great some of
the humor unintentional otherwise came
from him and all of the heart there's
heart along the way but all the big
heart moments I think come from the
character of viserys Targaryen all right
Ken tugging on our Ned Stark loving
heartstrings let's go back to Alden for
the final statement in round three
look I know he did a lot of terrible
things and I know that he even stepped
on someone that was cheering for him he
was like yeah my prince Damon crushed
with a dragon foot yes that did happen
but we're talking about heart we cannot
deny one of the most heartfelt moments
I've ever seen in any film or television
show is Damon helping viserys up onto
the throne in episode 8 lord of the
tides that Crown fell it's already an
urban legend sort of behind the scenes
story The Crown wasn't supposed to fall
both of these actors stay in it Damon
finally closes the book not on his story
but on the story of the brothers in a
moment that would make even the most
hardened Warrior cry I guarantee you
that's a that's a good behind the scenes
nugget that's much more fun behind the
scenes than who brought the Starbucks
cup okay so if we're looking at House of
the dragon as as all these wonderful
characters and and as you know Alden
apologizing for the actions of Damon but
again in this world it's sort of
enriching for a character to have those
multi-dimensions of Dr Jekyll and Mr
Hyde of it all but I feel like Ken made
such a compelling case that the series
even though we're not going to see this
person necessarily at least and not in
the present tense going forward had such
an effect on this show and was the
positive Beacon of light that you know
character is going to get into no good
on a showing House of the Dragon to have
a North star like that I think is
important it makes that scene between
both Patty and Matt when they're acting
in that moment all that more compelling
but I'm going to slightly give the edge
to the Elder Targaryen here in round
three so Ken knapsock goes up two to one
and is now on the verge of claiming
another binge Battle Victory but all in
Diaz putting up one hell of a fight
here's we kick off round number four and
it's gonna be why do you tune into these
shows to be shocked to be odd plot
twists and turns what was the most
shocking moment in season one of House
of the dragon all India's you have the
four
well my friends we've already addressed
one of the elephants in the room of Game
of Thrones season eight very
controversial split our fandom some
people claiming they would never watch
again and they did and we'd love to have
you back but the entire idea of are they
gonna shy away no because in the pilot
of this show not only do they lean all
the way in by mentioning Daenerys but
they go as far as to say it's all one
story what you saw with John and Danny
these characters are already concerned
about it the Song of Ice and Fire aegon
the conqueror's dream not only is it a
test for our lead character or one of
our leads rhaenyra it's the affirmation
from her father it re-contextualizes the
entire Targaryen line this would be the
equivalent of doing a Star Wars movie
200 years prior and having someone say
we think a Skywalker family will come
one day it was the most affirming here
it is it's a Saga now moment and nobody
saw it coming and we got to sit there
and say no you're too 200 years too
early viserys but we're glad you care
yeah it was a little like you're I
wouldn't say it's trying to write any
ships that were perceived from the end
of Game of Thrones but it is just a nice
Wink in the nod Ken to all those fans
who did stick with it and and whether
they enjoyed it or not they're still
showing up for House of the Dragon like
you so what was the most shocking moment
for Ken knapsock well look first I'll
say this my opponent over there that's a
great answer in many cases that is the
answer except for this I don't know if
it's shocking because hey these are
connected franchises HBO's gotta print
some money why not we can connect it and
I'm not even saying that cynically
because I loved it the most shocking
moment for me was in episode one it was
a very hotly debated one I don't want to
get it too much in the controversy of it
if it didn't work for you that's the
right answer but it is the death of Emma
Aaron Emma Targaryen if you will the
first wife the true love of viserys
Targaryen and the death was brutal
horrible and there's this great sequence
uh or a shocking sequence the violence
of it being shocking was not just the
only part of it there it was an
important moment because you have
Allison and Ranier in this world that
they are supposed to serve these roles
you get married you make kids you get
the babies out there you maybe you live
yeah maybe you're die that is your duty
that is your Battlefield how are these
two characters going to deal with it how
are they going to to circumnavigate any
issues or get through all this problem
they need to see it and the pillar the
signpost is this shocking horrendously
shocking horrible death of Emma Aaron
that killed viserys essentially in his
soul it was a sign points for them
signposts of them of this is you if
you're not careful birth death Life all
at the center of the show and it was
shocking and this again I keep saying
shocking shocking shocking if it hurt
you if it upset you I understand that
that's not the wrong answer but this is
a show targeted towards the prince
Demons of our real world who are not as
easily shocked as everyone else
sometimes the message isn't for you it's
for others I hope that Prince Demons of
the world stopped and saw the shocking
brutality of that death of Emma
Targaryen Emma Aaron it meant a lot I
hope they're not princes here on this
fancy a wonderful performance by the uh
actress uh Sam Brooke I believe in that
show also great in a season of Sherlock
uh so let's go back to the sort of the
the the maybe the Watson to kenza's
homes Alden Diaz for your rebuttal here
in round four
I would prefer to be the homes and he
can be the Mycroft but we will take that
oh I can give you that I can allow that
thank you thank you so much uh I I need
some sort of intelligence but yeah the
entire idea of shocking yes that was
brutal the death of Emma that was that
was actually bloody and and disgusting
and off-putting but at the same time I
think we all went into this knowing well
based on what we know about the show
even the most casual viewer would have
seen well I know that we need to get to
a place they keep talking about how
there's no mail heirs we need to get to
this place I think we all saw it coming
but what we didn't see coming is how egg
on stream factors in I think that taking
this and saying every King from here all
the way around and before all the way
down to Bobby B Robert Baratheon at the
beginning they had a responsibility
whether they knew it or not that Iron
Throne that maybe we said sometimes hey
the iron chair doesn't matter it has a
mystical importance that nobody could
have expected whatsoever
man you guys really good at this house
of the Dragon stuff uh can nap suck we
go back to you tell us more about this
shocking moment of yours
alden's talking about great themes about
the burden of leadership things you
can't factor in oh it's wonderful stuff
but people sitting on their couch are
like oh yeah it's connected to Danny oh
but they could not Overlook that
shocking brutal death of Emma Aaron and
the great thematic value that was within
that sequence it was violence in the
Game of Thrones world that we're used to
but it had great purpose to the point
where it was painful and maybe good
conversation discourse that was needed
but it made you sit up and take notice
and I think it even dominated over the
reveal at the end of the episode that
alden's talking about I mean look we're
talking about the intro to House of the
Dragon here and maybe next time you
don't have a tournament it's I guess
it's the very highfalutin version of
either a gender reveal party or having
some sort of shower it just it just
feels like it's anytime there's an event
in this world run in the other direction
uh all in Diaz you have the final Stave
in here first in round number four
well the show's called House of the
dragon and I think that after hearing so
much about them in Game of Thrones and
hearing about the Glory Days and only
really getting Danny and you know a
couple along the way maester Eamonn we
love you the entire idea of what
actually made them special finally came
to the Forefront here and it wasn't
dragon fire it was responsibility we now
finally got to understand that this
family was the steward against Darkness
they were the actual Guardians and they
never got to express that never told
anybody where the information died in
the bloodline the very topsy-turvy
bloodline we do not know but it's rare
to find something special in this world
and as much as I love Emma Aaron bloody
deaths are a dime a dozen in these lands
they are you can you can get a cheap
bloody death in house of the Dragon even
one is emotionally impacting as Ken's
most shocking moment speaking of the
last word in round four goes to knapsock
shocking violent deaths are a dime a
dozen in Game of Thrones but this one
had a different vibe to it it had had a
different purpose and
um the other thing look I love it I
really love it his his point I really
love that moment I just think this one
uh had a higher calling and a higher
purpose I hope it reached the intended
audience that needed to see this
deaths are a dime a dusted in Game of
Thrones and House of the Dragon a dime a
dozen much like tacos in Ken knapsock's
Mustang but if we're looking at the most
shocking moments I totally agree with
Canada this death during childbirth it
was brutal it was Bloody it was a
shocking moment but it was also the
moment that just sent social media into
a flurry when we were at the outset of
House of the Dragon but if you're
looking at the shocking moments I think
maybe the Bolder play behind the scenes
on the writing steps part on the The
Producers on the makers of this show
part was to be so foot forward with the
interconnectivity of these targaryens to
what we saw at the end of Game of
Thrones despite that controversy linking
this show I think was crucial regardless
if you were left cold by the end of Game
of Thrones if you've never seen Game of
Thrones you want to get in the house of
the Dragon first if you're one of those
but bless you I feel like that was the
shock that we needed there was awe with
watching somebody die in child as brutal
as what the you know um if you look at
Emma Aaron like this as like oh maybe
I'm rooting for that person it now
that's off the table and so we sort of
expect that we're propped up to expect
that from eight season to Game of
Thrones the interconnectivity I think
was something that was rewarding and it
did surprise me that they went there
that early with the pilot so by the
slimmest the margins Alden gets the
point and lo and behold here we are in a
tie-breaking round at number five well
earned by both parties so now we come to
that question a lot of times with these
tie breaker rounds what we like to do is
speculate now as Ken would say we want
to speculate responsibly but here's the
question on the table for each one of
you is which character would you like to
see get their own spin-off if we have
all the money in the world and this
company might not us HBO maybe us too I
don't make those kind of decisions which
character deserves their own spin-off in
this universe can't nap suck going to
you first well I'm trying to get you
guys to spin off a show called binge
picnic where we we just sit and chat
about movies here uh here is where I'm
going uh on my character there's a
spin-off and I'm cheating a little bit
because it's rumored to happen and then
this week we heard that it was uh as a
recording it's rumored to not happen uh
but maybe so it is the nine Voyages of
Lord Corliss Lauren uh the sea snake we
need to see this story it's fantastic
and uh in in expanding this universe so
to speak if you will uh we're gonna
maybe leave Westeros and not just simply
go to essos we're going to go around the
world these nine voyages that built this
important house it is the story of a
lord a high society person who is still
looked down upon and still had to make
his name Stephen Toussaint did such a
wonderful job at this character during
the show whether you want to go a little
young or whatever I don't know I would
hope it be him at least part of the show
I think there's a lot to tell there's a
lot to see that would be different but
it would be about this world and uh not
the one sitting on the Thrones the ones
the people around the globe or whatever
this world sits on George hasn't
answered that completely uh planetos uh
it would be fun to see all of it and see
this man make his name he's a fair of
oceans known as the sea snake you could
probably see him having a drink at the
channel marker in the Pacific Northwest
Alden Diaz which character would you
like to see get a spin-off well it's
interesting because Corliss Valerian a
character I love we've talked about a
lot of characters we've loved but all of
them are influenced by one who sat
proudly in the pilot at the great
Council the prologue of the entire
adventure and thus far since this is as
far back as we go the entire game of
thrones Saga the Old King King jaharis
Targaryen who everyone agrees people
that hate each other in this show agree
had the greatest Reign and he bookends
this show we see his Dragon there in the
finale Verma Thor Damon singing hoping
that they can bring this great Beast
back into the fold why wouldn't you want
to see the greatest king and the
greatest beast in their Heyday seeing a
Targaryen King who amazingly for this
world was really really good at it how
did that happen it could be a
godfather-esque project that ends
positively shockingly I would love to
see The jaharas Saga
it ends happy what in this universe I
feel like I love posting this question
about movies where if I put you to movie
theater which theater are you going into
you're going into theater a theater
based on the premise this is gonna be
like picture in picture because I really
want to see where both of these ideas
that you fellas have go can that's not
correct you for your rebuttal about the
sea snake and really expanding the
universe instead of sticking with the
Bloodlines that we know King jaharis man
great king great answer Michael Carter
Bob uh bib for tuna plays him in uh that
one little quick moment it's amazing fun
but here's the thing uh Alden if you're
pitching the show to the network I've
got nine voyagers that could be nine
seasons of content different cultures
different world a lot of action uh man
out on the sea oh man you're a brand day
you're a fine well they can go another
Direction
um here's here's King Jay Harris 50
years a piece
uh give him the Lambs
yeah you can marry that's the show
that's the show you want to go into the
high seas with Lord cordless floor I
don't know that you need that much Yacht
Rock accompaniment that might throw some
fans off but Ken you can make your own
soundtrack while you're enjoying the
program that you're spinning inside of
your head and maybe on the internet's
Rumor Mill back to you Alden Diaz
stumping for this Targaryen bloodline
and really how it all started I will
attempt to make this argument while
keeping sea shanties out of my head I
think that Jay Harris did more than just
sit around I think that in a show and
two shows that I've talked about
sometimes how much the throne doesn't
even matter how much of the kings are
bad at what they do how horrible and
sadistic they can be to show us a
Shining Light a paragon in this a Jedi
superhero s King I think is something
that if we're talking about Executives
they would absolutely love just tell
them some of the stories hey remember
that wall you guys love icons you guys
love iconography that everybody loves
what if a dragon flew up to that wall
and helped them Night's Watch just
annihilate with dragon fire black cloaks
and a golden King I think everybody
would immediately throw money out of Jay
Harris project Ken this is interesting
because the way that Alden is selling
this Targaryen show is along the lines
of your binge picnic pitch which is just
we're all sort of at peace and we're
just enjoying the landscape preparing
for all the madness to come can you have
the first final statement here in the
tie breaking round uh all right kids
what do you want you want another
targary on the throne and he just sits
there for a long time flights of dragons
to the wall or do you want to go to the
shores of Yeti see beautiful people
you've never seen before do you want to
travel pull out your swords and fight
serpents in the ocean you've got go
picture you got a lord cordless Lord
you've got the nine voyages yeah I mean
yeah the nine Seasons ten if you include
when he is in I don't know uh
Christopher cross's background band all
India's the final statement here in the
show goes to you for the win look no
disrespect to you Lord Corliss I love
you I love what you Bill I think you
have one of the most entertaining
marriages and all of Westeros we all
love rhaenys Targaryen but my friend I
have the Pirates of the Caribbean
Universe if I want to dive into that I
have things like hook I can get my
swashbuckling fix other places but I
cannot get my Game of Thrones iron
throne politicking here it's a great
Prospect going to other lands but when I
get there I can't help but feel like
I'll just missed Westeros and the
machinations at King's Landing
yeah this is tough it's it's what we
know and nobody knows that I love my
comfort foods places hotel lobby water
more than anything else but occasionally
you do need to get out there and see the
world and see what else is there and
going back to the other franchise that
both Alden and Ken love so dear much I'm
very happy with all the content we've
gotten in a galaxy far far away in that
limited time period if you start 30
years before the classic Trilogy 30 or
since a classic trilogy but I feel like
maybe we're starting to get to that
point where we need to get somewhere
else and stop cramming so much War into
this one time period I feel like if Game
of Thrones is going to get away from
that maybe you do need to follow the
Snee stake the the Snee stake would be
not at nine seasons of a good show a sea
snake that could be at least nine
seasons of a show and really Ken gets
the point here but it's really a win for
both of you because I want this
franchise to continue to make new series
new iterations why well because I enjoy
but also because is I really love
listening to Castro we talk because I
get so much out of knapsock and Diaz and
the information that they give us on a
weekly sometimes more than once a week
basis so Ken knapsack gets the win here
today but a sterling effort by his his
Protege who look if you follow Game of
Thrones lore and I'm sure everybody
watching does uh you better watch out
for this Diaz kid Ken he's going to
sneak up on you maybe take that Crown
from you look you lost today kid but it
doesn't mean you have to like it all
right this is the this is where this is
where it's at no look I loved uh talking
with Alderman on the show he uses uh
like 50 Cent words and when I speak you
can tell I still owe money uh but I I
absolutely love it here and uh but by
the way in his rebuttal the man said
hook I mean what a generational divide I
love it a lot of fun as always
oh the hook really it really does skew
down that generational one some people
love it some people not so much great
episode of our podcast Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong so let me reward Alden here
Alden you came up just short today as
far as of a competitive standpoint but
great arguments leveled in all five
rounds so let me ask you first well we
got a little bit of time here I'm giving
you the creative control over season two
of House of the Dragon where do you
think the show should go from where the
finale left us off I think the first
move is to re-establish the north I
really do I think that in terms of the
way that this season ended we didn't
talk about him today rest in peace
luceris valarian the sweetest little boy
who's the first casualty of War his
brother is on a different journey and I
think to show sort of you know yeah that
one went really South but this one is
about building a new relationship put us
back in Winterfell show us a dragon up
there in the snow building new
relationships all right so again I
imagine you're on board with that for
season two anything else that we need
sprinkled in there to make it a truly
memorable season of House of the Dragon
nah look more is afoot to war is upon us
uh and I I love it but uh I'm so
interested to see there was a moment
there in uh episode nine where rainis
comes up in the dragon pit and and
interrupts the coronation and she killed
a lot of people a lot of people have
some questions about that fans why why
why well don't you think the small folk
of King's Landing Westeros have an
opinion about that too how will this War
affect those who are less fortunate less
privileged and down below in flea bottom
that's going to be one of the things I
want to explore as well as stuff I love
what Alton said about going north uh
Starks even go up to my beloved Night's
Watch where the old Grumps like me are
just sitting in the cold I'd love to see
that too uh kind of expand the story out
from the walls of King's Landing it's
it's the wonderful thing about shows and
franchises like this is that even when
there isn't a new episode coming up this
particular Sunday there's still so much
to talk about to get excited for the
future to look back on the past with the
showing House of the dragon and by proxy
Game of Thrones so Ken AppLock takes the
binge battle over a very game opponent
in Alden Diaz making a wonderful debut
here on binge battle I would love to
have you back on the show sooner rather
than later in the meantime we mentioned
Caster we talked um I didn't know that
there was a radio signal all the way out
there in Octo uh where can everybody
find you in the world talking about all
these great and wonderful uh fun
properties that we love celebrating yeah
if you manage to get past the old man
drinking the green milk there's a nice
area to set up a tower and it works
really well for my purposes and that's
and sometimes that old man is Ken
drinking the green milk and ignoring me
and and I I talk about Star Wars there I
dive into all the shows but the core of
it is really interviewing people in the
Star Wars space including the author of
why we love Star Wars Ken knapsock
diving into their Star Wars Journeys and
sort of an inside the actor studio type
way you can also find me on casually
talk which Ken will talk more about I'm
sure I wrote recently for star trek.com
uh doing all types of stuff across all
these fandoms and if you follow me on
Twitter I'm sure I'll tell you what's
next
uh Ken knapsock I do enjoy Castro we
talk not just for you and Alden but also
because you have a lot of wonderful
personalities that pop in and out there
giving you their thoughts from time to
time uh where can all the kids find you
what is the Hub of Ken knapsock easy
spot is just go to kenappstock.com you
can get there to things like casually
talk yeah also Andres compare uh Cabrera
Rachel Cushing Levine are on there as
well and others uh Nikki Kumar Lauren
Romo and more uh for center with Joseph
scrimshaw Jennifer Landa uh but go there
uh to find my music show pop rock and
radio I am an old 90s rock DJ and stand
up dates including oh I'm kind of got
something to do with this big taping
going on December 3rd in Los Angeles a
dynasty typewriter I'm uh maybe helping
warm up the crowd for some blow hard
coming in to do some comedy after me
yeah that that bull hardest me thank you
Ken for taking me up uh my new Comedy
Hour is taping two shows December 3rd
Saturday night here in Los Angeles you
get tickets at
markellis.live enough about me Casper we
talk is where you all want to go for
more info for some really great insights
and some Divergent opinions on all
things House of the dragon and Game of
Thrones what we've seen what we expect
next and everywhere in between speaking
of that once again rottentomatoes.com
that's where you go for your TV your
movies your info your ratings your
reviews all the good stuff that we love
in the world of entertainment for your
ears and your eyes so for Alden Diaz Ken
knapsaw Christian rubalcaba our
wonderful producer his amazing dog Draco
I am merely Mark Ellison thanks for
tuning in to this edition of binge
battle and we'll see you real soon right
here on Rotten Tomatoes
thank you
Bring It On